le mot qui revient le plus souvent c'est
c'est une insoumise qui n'a peur de rien
et ça ça fait peur dans les réseaux
politiques
c'est que le Royal vous aimez que l'on
vous appelle madame la députée madame la
ministre est-ce que ça vous fait plaisir
oui ça me fait plaisir de d'être
féminisé dans les dans le vocabulaire
parce que je pense que si les titres de
pouvoir ne sont utilisés qu'au masculin
ça veut dire tout simplement que l'on
considère que si les femmes occupent un
moment bref ces fonctions là ce n'est
qu'un accident de l'histoire il paraît
que sur votre carte de visite nous
écrivez donc député avec un e oui oui
parce que je suis fière d'être une femme
je pense que j'ai quelque chose à
apporter en tant que femme à la vie
politique et je n'ai jamais cherché à
imiter les hommes dans l'exercice de mes
fonctions tant ministérielles que
élective donc vous à 38 ans vous avez
été ministre de l'Environnement c'était
est-ce que c'était quelque chose que
vous désiriez fortement est-ce que
c'était un rêve
lorsque vous étiez plus jeune non jamais
je n'aurais pensé pouvoir atteindre
cette expérience ministérielle cette
réalité là je crois qu'il y a à la fois
une suite de chance formidable dans ma
vie et en même temps peut-être qui s'est
conjugué avec une farouche volonté de
faire quelque chose de ma vie et les
événements m'ont aidés les événements en
même temps vous avez fait Sciences Po
Lena oui donc c'est quelque chose quand
même qui s'est dessiné assez tôt vous
aviez envie d'être d'intervenir dans la
vie sociale et politique à l'origine
petite fille je me suis dit j'ai pris
très très tôt conscience que c'est par
l'école que je pouvais m'en sortir m'en
sortir c'est à dire ne pas ressembler
aux femmes de ma famille qui étaient des
femmes soumises obéissantes n'ayant
aucune autonomie financière
intellectuelle et je me suis dit qu'il
fallait que je m'en sorte par l'école
ce qui veut dire que c'était d'une
certaine manière une revanche sociale
pour vous une revanche plutôt de femme à
l'origine une revanche de femmes et
surtout que j'ai vu mes sœurs sacrifier
c'est à dire que ma chance aussi ça a
été d'être au milieu d'une très grande
fratrie puisque nous étions 8 enfants
que ma mère a eu 8 enfants à 9 ans vous
êtes là quatrième et les filles dans
cette famille n'avaient pas le droit de
faire des études et les garçons devaient
obligatoirement embrasser la carrière
militaire et donc tous nos destins
étaient prédestinés et mes sœurs ont
donc été sacrifiées puisqu'elles étaient
les aînés et ensuite moi j'étais une
insoumise mais j'ai pu le faire parce
que j'ai vu d'autres enfants sacrifiés
avant moi en tant que femme et j'ai
bénéficié de cette chance votre père
était quelqu'un d'autoritaire puisqu'il
était il était militaire mais est-ce
qu'il était très autoritaire très
autoritaire ont été militaires jusqu'à
ce que j’avais prêt à l'âge de 10 ans
c'était donc un pouvoir masculin bien
sûr
mépris pour les femmes enfin tout mon
enfance a été bercé sur un discours de
femmes comme seconde catégorie etc une
famille de droite et c'est peut-être ça
aussi qui m'a éveillé à la politique
comment votre père a vécu vous votre
ascension et votre cheminement écoutez
la famille a éclater à ce moment-là
puisque c'était après Mai 68 donc il a
toujours expliqué que finalement ma mère
avait perdu la raison après Mai 68 que
les enfants c'était donc
la famille avec la classe à ce moment-là
et j'en ai aussi bénéficié cette triste
à dire mais le
tout foires familial ayant explosé c'est
ce qui m'a aussi permis de partir
à Paris de faire Sciences Po d'obtenir
mon indépendance avec cette bourse de
service public que j'ai obtenu avec les
soutiens de mes professeurs et donc j'ai
aussi bénéficié de cette chape de plomb
qui qui sautait dont on parle bénéficier
les
les trois enfants qui étaient avant moi
donc à un moment donné tout s'est fait
finalement assez naturellement oui
douloureusement mais
cette épreuve de l'adolescence ce
conflit très très fort très violent très
traumatisant
d'abord ça m'a aussi de donner l'envie
de donner aussi l'enfant c'est une
adolescence paisible à mes enfants je
crois que c'est un acquis déjà essentiel
et en même temps ça m'a aussi donné
l'habitude de me battre de me dire que
rien n'était acquis et d'apprendre à
compter sur mes propres forces de ne pas
venir justement du sérail est-ce que ça
vous a gêné dans votre carrière ou au
contraire ça a été un atout pour vous ça
m'a gêné parce que si je n'avais pas eu
de chance aussi exceptionnelles du
hasard aussi des choses même si j'ai su
saisir le hasard quand il passait jamais
je l'aurais pu réaliser ce que j'ai fait
ce que je suis aujourd'hui mais je crois
que c'est en même temps ça me donne une
force intérieure incomparable alors donc
vous vous évoluez essentiellement quand
même dans un univers masculin puisque en
politique il y a quand même
malheureusement et toujours beaucoup
plus d'hommes que de femmes
comment ça se passe comment vous êtes
perçu et comment vous femme vous êtes
arrivés dans cet univers d'homme comment
je suis arrivée par mes propres forces
je crois par mais en même temps grâce à
des hommes grâce à des hommes
grâce à mon conjoint d'ailleurs François
Hollande c'est lui qui m'a qui m'a
intégré dans les cercles initiaux qui
m'a fait connaître l'entourage de
François Mitterrand à l'époque qui
préparait la campagne électorale en 1980
donc ce qu'il faut dire que donc
François Hollande votre mari donc été
député oui pendant il nous a connu à
léna votre mari était étonnée de votre
parcours oui
il vous en a voulu un moment donné vous
a jalousé disons non au contraire il m'a
toujours soutenu et je crois que ça
aussi c'est une force c'est-à-dire
qu'une femme de pouvoir puisque c'est
votre expression ou une femme politique
ne peut pas réussir sans le soutien un
couple politique c'est trop dur déjà un
homme politique souvent détruit sa vie
de couple de sa vie familiale donc si
j'ai réussi ce parcours là aussi c'est
parce que mon conjoint est aussi
impliqué dans la politique et qu'il m'a
toujours soutenue même s'il m'a toujours
trouvé bizarre que j'ai réussi ce compte
tenu de mon tempérament c'est vrai ça
lui semble bizarre pourquoi ça leur
semble tous bizarre
parce que j'ai une certaine liberté de
parole le mot qui revient le plus
souvent c'est une insoumise qui n'a peur
de rien et ça ça fait peur dans les
réseaux politiques où il y a des règles
convenues où il y a des codes où il y a
des clans et souvent remarqué que les
femmes sont beaucoup plus
individualistes que les hommes qui qui
réussissent en politique réussissent
parce qu'elles ont leur front parler et
que c'est ça leur atout essentiel oui et
non parce que c'est justement parfois
handicap je pense qu'elle est davantage
au public parce qu'elles ont cette
franchise que les hommes politiques se
refusent à eux-mêmes mais en même temps
elle s'affaiblissent aussi dans les jeux
de pouvoir parce qu'on se méfie de
quelqu'un qui a sa liberté de parole
est-ce que lorsque l'on dit femme de
pouvoir vous ne vous reconnaissez pas
ensemble incongru non je me reconnais
vous le laisse parce que je le
revendique oui je l'assume
j'ai envie d'être une femme de pouvoir
parce que mais pas n'importe quel
pouvoir le jour où je sentirai que je ne
peux plus changer les choses autour de
moi ou je ne peux plus avoir de de
d'action opérationnelle possible je
ferai autre chose et donc pour moi le
pouvoir c'est d'abord changer
concrètement ce qui se passe autour de
moi c'est la réalisation de projet que
ce soit dans un mandat local que ce soit
en tant que député que ce soit en tant
que ministre j'ai toujours eu cette
passion de de la concrétisation des
choses on va souvent reprocher d'en
faire trop combien de fois j'ai entendu
quand j'étais mise de l'environnement
que j'en faisais trop et j'ai quoi en
faire trop alors voilà c'était c'est ça
que je comptais c'est que je pense qu'un
responsable politique ou une femme
d'action ou de pouvoir n'en fait jamais
trop on est là pour en faire trop ça
signifie
trop travailler ou en faire trop sur le
plan médiatique parce qu'on vous a
reprochait
de trop les médias donc les aider c'est
quand même un rep qui est revenu par
exemple lorsque vous avez été
photographié avec votre dernier enfant
parce que ça c'est important vous êtes
maire de quatre enfants donc dans je ne
sais plus quel journal je crois par
image oui vous savez il y a beaucoup
d'hypocrisie parce que ce qu'on tolère
des hommes on l'a pas toléré d'une femme
ça fait ça écoutez ça fait des années
que les hommes politiques
montrent leurs exhibent leurs enfants
et moi parce que j'avais un enfant qui
faisait partie de mon aussi de mon
identité politique je l'assumais en tant
que tel je ne voulais pas j'ai jamais
voulu sacrifier ma fonction de femme de
mère à ma fonction politique je ne vois
pas pourquoi je leur ai sacrifié et il
fait de l'assumer aussi de ne pas le
cacher alors qu'on m'avait sollicité
c'est pas moi qui suis allé chercher les
journalistes j'ai même entendu dire que
ça veut dire on m'a dit l'autre jour sur
France Inter la semaine dernière que
j'avais vendu ses photos à match enfin
c'était épouvantable et souvent les
mêmes journalistes qui m'ont sollicité
ont parfois été les mêmes à me compliqué
donc mais c'est vrai peut-être que je
n'aurais pas dû le faire compte tenu de
cela je ne sais pas il y a encore un
tabou sur les femmes de pouvoir
puisque j'ai été condamné c'est vrai par
beaucoup de journalistes et parce que ce
qui prouve aussi qu'il y a un tabou
c'est que on admet pas d'une femme de
pouvoir qu'elle soit en même temps une
mère mais vous savez de toute façon il y
a on s'en sort jamais parce que une
femme de pouvoir qui n'a pas d'enfant
lui dit vous n'avez pas d'enfant donc
vous n'êtes pas une femme comme tout le
monde si elle a des enfants lui dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait là le premier de
s'occuper de ses enfants de toute façon
on s'en sort jamais donc autant tracer
sa route je sais que ça vous énerve
lorsque l'on vous demande justement
comment vous faites avec vos enfants
puisque en général vous dites mais on ne
demanderait pas ça
me demande jamais de ça un homme donc là
il y a quelque chose qui vous semble
injuste oui je pense que c'est assez
injuste parce que quand on demande ça
une femme si on sous-entend c'est donc
que vous faites mal votre travail ou
alors c'est que vous êtes une mauvaise
mère alors comment on le demande pas un
homme c'est on ne met pas en cause ni
une fonction ni l'autre donc c'est plus
injuste oui et en même temps comment
nier que la responsabilité première de
l'ambiance familiale disons que c'est ce
qu'il y a de plus important que que
l'éducation sans stricte elle repose
d'abord sur la mer c'est vrai qu'est-ce
qui vous semble le plus avoir vous ayez
le plus sacrifié
qu'est-ce que j'ai le plus sacrifié
je ne sais pas encore je ne sais pas
encore mais c'est une question qui
m'angoisse c'est-à-dire que je ne sais
pas si
mes enfants vivent bien mais absences ou
ma passion extérieure au milieu familial
pour l'instant j'ai le sentiment qu'il
la vive bien mais tout parents se
rassure les parents sont toujours
aveugles sur les souffrances secrètes
d'un enfant j'ai entendu beaucoup de
enfin quelques femmes en politique dire
qu'à un moment donné il ne fallait il
fallait faire attention ne pas être trop
féminine en même temps rester féminine
sinon on fait peur comment vous vous
avez vous avez j'ai envie de dire
négocié tout cela en étant moi-même je
crois et puis les choses sont tellement
arrivées par hasard que je n'ai pas eu
le temps de faire de calcul
c'est impossible de jouer une comédie
c'est impossible les électeurs le voient
tout de suite téléspectateurs le voient
tout de suite c'est impossible de jouer
la comédie vous n'êtes pas dit il faut
que je porte tel tailleur que je me
coupe les cheveux je ne sois pas trop
maquillée ou attention
ce genre parce que chaque fois que on
m'a donné des conseils que j'ai suivi
par faiblesse ça ne m'a jamais réussi
on vous aide à donner oui oui
ça m'est arrivé de temps en temps
qu'est-ce qu'on vous disait par exemple
je me souviens pas
quand j'étais munition de musique
j'étais pas habillée assez ministre que
je ne fallait pas que je mette des jupes
à fleurs c'est ça en relation avec
l'image
des bêtises quoi et vous êtes rendu
compte qu'en fin de compte ça ne servait
à rien oui qu'il fallait être bien dans
sa peau qu'il fallait il y avait
tellement à se mobiliser dans son
énergie dans son intelligence dans son
action
que le reste il fallait tolérance sur le
reste et d'abord d'être bien
être bien en harmonie avec soi-même
qu'est-ce qui vous semble avoir changé
le plus en vous c'est peut-être le
comment dirais l'éducation à la
résistance c'est la découverte de
ressources intérieures que je ne
connaissais pas avec les risques que ça
en pas avec la dureté que cela donne
parce que je crois que une des
conséquences c'est peut-être d'avoir
acquis une certaine dureté les épreuves
les coûts on prend beaucoup de coups
quand même en politique ça donne une
certaine dureté contre laquelle il faut
réagir vous pourriez imaginer être
président de j'insiste pour vous parce
que vous dites de la République
je pense que c'est pas bon de répondre à
une question comme celle-là parce qu'à
la fois on pourrait se dire il faut que
je dise oui sinon je me mets en
situation d'infériorité par rapport à un
homme qui dira sans hésiter oui et en
même temps dire oui c'est c'est tombé
dans une caricature de la politique
entre laquelle je veux je veux lutter
oui mais comme ça n'a jamais existé
au même titre qu'un homme pourquoi pas
est-ce que les Français sont prêts à
désigner une femme comme président de la
République je ne sais pas je me poser
réellement la question est-ce que vous
c'est quelque chose qui
qui peut vous plaire
on imagine dans l'exercice du pouvoir
c'est l'idée
de faire une campagne électorale ce qui
me plaît c'est la conquête
par l'action d'un mandat électif ce qui
me plaît c'est le fonctionnement de la
démocratie ce qui me plaît c'est la
réaction des citoyens ce qui me plaît
c'est le suffrage universel donc le
suffrage universel suprême étant
l'élection présidentielle si je continue
dans la politique
pourquoi pas
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]